so i'll give you 10 million bucks  tell me  how many people we need  okay how long it will take us to prepare  this to bring  the world trade center down you need  dozens of operatives you get access to  the core columns in the in in in the  buildings it would take months it would  take months interestingly we had a  elevator modernization the largest in in  the world ever  going on the nine months prior to 9 11  who had that contract ace elevator who  should have had an otis elevator who  installed these elevators and maintained  them up until the time ace elevator had  85 employees in the building  at the time the the towers were hit and  they fled it was a scandal documented in  usa today uh and  the  they these are the experts who could  help rescue the firefighters yeah so so  that that's a plausible  undercover